In 1989, Japan's Shinkansen bullet train had a problem. It was fast, really fast, like pushing 170 miles per hour fast. But every time it exited a tunnel, it was loud. The noise was coming from a variety of sources, but whenever a train sped into a tunnel, it pushed waves of atmospheric pressure through the other end. The air exited tunnels with a sonic boom that could be heard 400 meters away. In dense residential areas, that was a huge problem. So, an engineering team was brought in to design a quieter, faster and more efficient train, and they had one secret weapon, Ajinakatsu, the general manager of the technical development department was a bird watcher. Different components of the redesigned bullet train were based on different birds. Owls
1989年，日本的新干线子弹头列车遇到了一个问题。它速度极快，真的非常快，时速甚至能达到170英里（约274公里）。但每次它驶出隧道时，都会发出巨大的噪音。噪音有各种各样的来源，每当列车高速冲进隧道时，它就会把大气压力波推向另一端。空气带着音爆从隧道中冲出，400米外都能听到。在人口稠密的住宅区，这是一个巨大的问题。因此，一个工程团队被请来设计一辆更安静、更快、更高效的列车，他们有一个秘密武器——技术开发部总经理中津井（Ajinakatsu）是一名观鸟爱好者。重新设计的高铁的不同部件都以不同的鸟类为原型。猫头鹰
inspired the pantograph, that's the rig that connects the train to the electric wires above. Nikatsu modeled the redesign after their feathers, reducing noise by using the same serrations and curvature that allow them to silently swoop down to catch prey. The Adelie penguin, whose smooth body allows it to swim and slide effortlessly, inspired the pantograph supporting shaft, redesigned for lower wind resistance, and perhaps most notable of all was the Kingfisher. The Kingfisher is a bird that dives into water to catch its prey.
启发了受电弓的设计，也就是连接列车与上方电线的那个装置。中津将其重新设计得像猫头鹰的羽毛一样，利用让它们能够无声俯冲抓捕猎物的相同锯齿和曲率来降低噪音。阿德利企鹅身体光滑，能够毫无阻力地游动和滑行，这启发了受电弓支撑轴的设计，重新设计后降低了风阻，而其中最引人注目的或许莫过于翠鸟。翠鸟是一种潜入水中捕食猎物的鸟类。
The unique shape of its beak allows it to do that while barely making a splash. Nakatsu took that shape to the design table. The team shot bullets shaped like different train nose models down a pipe to measure pressure waves and drop them into water to measure the splash size. The quietest nose design was the one modeled most closely after the Kingfisher's beak. When the redesign debuted in 1997, it was 10% faster, used 15% less electricity, and stayed under the 70 decibel noise limit
它那独特的喙形使其在入水时几乎不会溅起水花。中津把这个形状带到了设计桌上。团队将不同列车车头模型形状的子弹射入管道以测量压力波，并将它们投入水中以测量水花大小。最安静的车头设计是那个最贴近翠鸟喙部的模型。当这个重新设计的列车在1997年首次亮相时，它的速度提高了10%，耗电量减少了15%，并且将噪音控制在
in residential areas. And it did all that with the wings of an owl, the belly of a penguin, and the nose of a Kingfisher. There's a name for design like this. It's called Biomimicry. The people who design our world usually never take a biology class. Believe it or not. So they're novices in how the world works.
住宅区70分贝的限制以下。它这一切的实现，依靠的是猫头鹰的翅膀、企鹅的腹部以及翠鸟的喙。这种设计有一个名字，叫做仿生学。负责设计我们这个世界的人，通常从来不上生物学课。信不信由你。所以他们是了解世界运作方式的新手。
That's Janine Benius. Back in 1997, she wrote the book that coined the term biomimicry. It told the story of the innovations in computing, energy, and health that were inspired by structures in the natural world. Stick like a gecko, compute like a cell, even run a business like a redwood forest. Benius has since worked as a consultant for various companies, trying to get them to understand how to take design ideas from nature. That might mean studying prairie dog burrows to build better air ventilation systems, mimicking shark skin to create bacteria-resistant plastic surfaces for hospitals, or arranging wind turbines in the same drag-reducing pattern
那是珍妮·贝纽斯（Janine Benius）。早在1997年，她就写下了创造“仿生学”这个词的书。书中讲述了受自然世界结构启发的计算、能源和健康领域创新故事。像壁虎一样粘住，像细胞一样计算，甚至像红杉林一样经营企业。此后，贝纽斯一直担任多家公司的顾问，试图让他们了解如何从自然界中汲取设计灵感。这可能意味着研究土拨鼠的洞穴来建造更好的空气通风系统，模仿鲨鱼皮为医院创造抗细菌的塑料表面，或者以相同的减阻模式排列风力涡轮机——
that schools of fish swim in. Designers get inspiration from a lot of different places, but Benius thinks many of them could benefit from looking more at the natural world. So there's a lot of sort of looking at what other people have done, and what they do is they look at all the others and they get ideas. They literally do, you know, a lot of, a lot of designers have lots of magazines that they
这种模式正是鱼群游动时所采用的。设计师从很多不同的地方获得灵感，但贝纽斯认为，他们中的许多人可以通过更多地观察自然界而从中受益。所以，很多人其实就是在看别人做过什么，而他们所做的就是看所有其他人，然后从中获得灵感。他们真的会，你知道的，很多设计师有很多杂志供他们
look through, they tear those out, they put them on inspiration boards, but they're looking at other human technologies. Her idea was simple. Designers should get in the habit of bringing a biologist to the table and let them help solve problems by mimicking nature and there are three main ways they can do that. You know you can mimic it its form or its shape. You might create a paint for a building that when it dries it's got the same structure as self-cleaning leaves.
翻阅，他们把那些页面撕下来，贴在灵感板上，但他们看的都是其他人类的技术。她的想法很简单。设计师应该养成带一个生物学家上谈判桌的习惯，让他们通过模仿自然来帮助解决问题，而他们可以通过三种主要方式做到这一点。你知道，你可以模仿它的形式或形状。你可能会为一座建筑创造一种涂料，当它变干时，它具有与自清洁树叶相同的结构。
Lotus leaves are notoriously great. They let rainwater clean the leaf because they have these bumps. And the rainwater balls up on the bumps and then it perils away the dirt. So that lotus effect is physical. And you can create a physical structure on the outside of any product.
莲叶出名地好。它们让雨水来清洁叶子，因为它们有这些凸起。雨水在凸起上凝结成水珠，然后把灰尘带走。所以莲花效应是物理的。你可以在任何产品的外部创造一种物理结构。
Imagine that on the outside of your car, rainwater would clean your car. So that's mimicking form. But there's also mimicking process, the processes in the natural world. It might even be how you mimic, how ants communicate in order to efficiently find sources of food or new places to live. And those processes, that self-organization, has been mimicked in software. You know, in things like autonomous cars and how they're going to move in flocks through the city by talking to one another. That's mimicking nature's process. And then you jump up to the level of mimicking
想象一下，在汽车外部，雨水就能帮你洗车。这就是模仿形式。但也有模仿过程的，即自然界中的过程。它甚至可能是你如何模仿蚂蚁的交流方式，以便高效地找到食物来源或新的居住地。这些过程，即自我组织，已经在软件中得到了模仿。你知道，在自动驾驶汽车之类的事情中，它们将如何通过相互交流成群结队地在城市中穿行。这就是模仿自然的过程。然后你跳跃到模仿的层面——
whole ecosystems, right? There's a thing called, that's a buzzword right now that's really hot called the circular economy, which is essentially, you know, industry saying, you know, there are, there should be no such thing as a byproduct in our manufacturing facility that goes to landfill. It should be used by something else, right? And at the end of a product's life, that product should be upcycled into something else. It's being called the circular economy.
整个生态系统，对吧？现在有一个被称为当下非常热门的流行词，叫做“循环经济”，这本质上就是，你知道的，工业界在说，你知道的，在我们的制造设施中不应该存在最终进入垃圾填埋场的副产品这一说法。它应该被其他东西利用，对吧？在一个产品生命的终点，该产品应该被升级回收（upcycled）成别的东西。这被称为循环经济。
Ecosystems do that really, really, really well. You've got a log on the forest floor and those materials move up into the body of the fungus that eats it. Those materials move up into a mouse, and that mouse material moves up into a hawk, right? And if you think about that, is what we'd like to do with local materials
生态系统在这方面做得非常非常非常好。森林地面上有一根原木，这些材料进入了吃它的真菌体内。这些材料接着进入老鼠体内，而老鼠体内的材料又进入了鹰体内，对吧？如果你仔细想想，这正是我们希望对本地材料所做的事情
being upcycled constantly in our cities, for instance. Those ecosystem lessons are really big for us. And that's the end goal for biomimetic design, making products, systems, and cities functionally indistinguishable from the natural world. Life has been around on Earth for 3.8 billion years, and what designers are starting to realize is that that is a lot of research and development time. The people who design our world have a lot to learn from the natural world. All they have to do is take a look.
例如，在我们的城市中不断被升级回收。这些生态系统的教训对我们来说非常重大。这也是仿生设计的最终目标，即让产品、系统和城市在功能上与自然界无法区分。生命在地球上已经存在了3.8亿年，设计师们开始意识到，那是一大笔研发时间。设计我们世界的人们有很多东西需要向自然界学习。他们所要做的，只是看上一眼。
dot com slash vox. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
dot com slash vox。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。